you believe in UFOs yeah oh my god
really yeah yeah see I believe in
there's other other life-forms out there
I don't think they're coming here they
might the thing they might what why not
think it but just because here's here's
one thing I do believe most people are
full shit you know it comes to like most
of their stories like it's it's hard to
find a person that could just tell you
what happened based on what they really
remember people want to jazz things up
and they want to add salt and pepper
yeah they have sex with men that don't
they don't necessarily tell you the
truth they tell you what they think is
gonna be an engaging story that kind of
represents the truth maybe especially
when it's a weird thing like you saw
something in the sky what did you really
see how long did you look at it for how
many seconds was it well I mean here's
the problem I have with UFOs and I
believe there are UFOs but I don't think
they're coming here that means you say
that because that means they're Tech
first of all if they're coming here that
means their technology is far way more
advanced than ours
right so why would they care if people
saw them they would show up if I was an
alien and I was that far ahead of us
I would lay in that bitch right in the
middle of Times Square and be like what
we require why would you do that but why
wouldn't I why am i hiding in fields
where nobody can see us are you aware of
how we treat uncontacted tribes yes to a
point but the point but what I'm saying
is if you're that power advanced they
know if they're coming here they know
they're they're way smarter than that's
right because they've traveled here
right and we don't even know other from
far distances we can't even imagine and
they're here they don't have to hide
it's just like they do it because they
have to hide or do you think maybe they
do it because we can't handle it because
we can't handle it why would they care
if we could handle it or not because
here's the problem whenever any
civilization has ever encountered a
civilization far superior to them the
results have always been catastrophic
every single time every time Europeans
have invaded North America
every time the Spanish visited the
Mexicans every time that this has
happened it's been a disaster and this
is human beings if there was something
that came down here from another planet
it was so unbelievably sophisticated
that it could travel through vast
distances in space and had
insurmountable impossible technology
that we would look to it for all of our
answers it would become our new daddy it
would completely disrupt all of our
governments it would disrupt all of our
religions it would disrupt every single
belief system we have and people would
fall apart they wouldn't know what to do
psychologically it would be devastating
look I'm not a doctor a psychologist but
I know most people would not be able to
handle it I understand that but why
would they care because that's my whole
point because why would they care about
because it would be affecting our
culture it wouldn't care but why
wouldn't they care but why would I care
we care about animals bro there's a
reason we have wildlife protection
agencies we have that because we care
about animals and animals don't even
know we're a thing if you're a deer
living in the forest and you're two
years old you might not have ever even
seen a person you don't even know what
the fuck we are but we're trying to keep
those deer alive we spend billions of
dollars every year protecting them we do
that because we care about wildlife if
we cared about a rare monkey that we
found in Indonesia in the course of
strange monkey we would do whatever we
could to make sure that monkeys
populations thrived if there was a way
to help them I mean that's one of the
reasons why zoos exist they take rare
animals they try to breed them in
captivity and but we're also sharing the
same earth
well then maybe they look at the
universe that way and okay nuclear
civilizations like our civilization I
mean our civilization is a very
dangerous one because we're we're a
bunch of semi hairless monkeys with
nuclear weapons
I mean we're fucking nuts bro oh yeah
we're obsessed with sex we jack off to
our phones where we're taking pills to
keep our dick hard we're all on speed
this these are we're at and we lie we
lie about shit we lie about things that
people did to us we pretend people think
did worse things we pretend that we
didn't do things to people we lie about
stealing we lie about money we lie about
all kinds of things I mean people are so
so you're
you're thinking aliens are thinking
about all that before they come down of
course they would why wouldn't why
wouldn't I guess I'm coming from a human
point of view where we don't give a shit
about anything there's a thing that's
not true we do give a shit about things
that's why when you go to the Galapagos
Islands you're not allowed to take your
shoes you walked around Los Angeles and
walk around the Galapagos Island because
people have done that and they've gotten
seeds from their shoes stuck in the sand
over there in the ground over there and
then new plants grow that are invasive
species that we're worried about
ecosystems that we really account that's
why humans that's where we're worried
about invasive species